hi there
steve kaufman here um
i'm going to uh talk a bit today about
uh language learning
uh and the ipad
where i put it it's over there
uh because i um i'm committed to making
a speech here in a local library about
language learning in the age of the ipad
and i will be doing the same in europe
so i've been sort of doing a bit of
reading collecting my thoughts
and i would like to get your input i
think
what i'm going to say basically is that
the the ipad and i don't want to promote
one company's
product but it's kind of the
the sort of uh
most widely recognized brand name for a
new phenomenon which is these electronic
tablets that are going to enable us to
have really a very powerful computer
uh at our fingertips that theoretically
can be connected at all times to the
world to other people other people's
ideas uh other sources of information
and um
personally i think the ipad
in that sense as an electronic tablet is
absolutely revolutionary and i have been
using my ipad more and more for a
variety of things including language
learning but also for reading
and
the other day i decided that i wanted to
read a book called the rational optimist
i had heard about the book i didn't know
quite what the name was i just went to
amazon on my ipad i
searched for optimist and up came the
rational optimist by matt ridley i
immediately bought the book
for seven dollars
and read it on the sort of kindle uh
application
uh on my ipad and so within a day or two
i had the book and i had read it
it's just an example of the kind of
world we are living in
um one of the criticisms of of the
internet and constant connectivity is
that we are always prone to
jump from hyperlink to hyperlink and not
really engross ourselves in any one
subject
i think any tool you can use it however
you want people flip channels people
flip through books some people never
read books they read magazines if you
want to read a book it has become much
more convenient to do it now because any
book you think of you can buy it right
away and start reading it
now matt ridley's book the rational
optimist i bought it because there is a
fellow called freedman who keeps on
commenting on my blog about how the
world is headed for disaster and if we
don't do something we'll run out of
resources and global warming is going to
be so damaging and he just goes on and
on in this doomsday scenario and i'm
tired of listening to him i try to point
out
that
every similar prediction of doom and
gloom in the past has proven to be
inaccurate
and uh i had i was aware that there was
a book that described this in greater
detail so i got a hold of the book
very interesting book i very much
recommend that you read it
the basic theme of the book is
that it has been the
sort of constantly accelerating exchange
of goods but even more than goods of
ideas
and particularly in an environment not
of
exchanging like for like
but where
some people are specialized in some
product or some technology or some ideas
and other people are ex specialized in
others and they exchange these and
therefore they
dramatically increase
the range of products and ideas that are
available to them and this has been
accelerating and
uh ridley traces through a very
interesting sort of summary of of world
history and different civilizations and
periods of of growth in in civilization
and periods of of decline and typically
the decline was caused by an excess of
government intervention
and regulation
and other measures that prevented or
discouraged people from exchanging goods
and ideas
and the greater the freedom of exchange
and the greater the freedom of
expression
uh the better off we all become
and
you know there is this sort of uh
random
unorganized undirected spontaneous
bottom-up activity by human beings
connected with other human beings and
the larger the community the more
rapidly we come up with new ideas new
solutions to problems and so forth
uh and today
in order to progress we need a
collaborative brain collaborative
knowledge
collective brain i think he talks about
it and wherever a community
had enjoyed this kind of interaction and
then was isolated from
the rest of the world they tended to
stagnate they tended to lose skills that
they had because there were fewer fewer
people with these specialized skills
and as a result ridley points out that
uh since 1970 the world cereal harvest
has more than doubled on the same land
base and therefore if that had not
happened either we wouldn't have as many
people alive today and of course i don't
have the number but i think the
population has probably doubled during
that time as well
we would have had to use twice as much
land in order to grow
uh the same amount of food assuming that
that was even possible
it's also true
that uh according to uh d lal who must
be an indian writer that the consumption
of the poor has grown over the last 20
years
twice as fast as the world average there
has according to the united nations
there's a decline
in world poverty
so that we are more and more of us
living better and better
uh pollution i mean a car traveling at
normal speed apparently pollutes less
than a car who parked somewhere in 1970
would pollute just through leakage
so apparently everything has gone down
in cost with the exception of health and
education
and if we look at the united states the
cost of educating someone from
kindergarten to grade 12 after inflation
has increased by 350 since 1970. yet the
incarceration rate in the united states
has increased 700 percent and
educational outcomes are at best the
same or worse so we're spending three
and a half times as much money for
poorer outcomes why is this might it
have something to do with our education
system with a classroom with the
authoritarian top-down
isolated
uh
protectionist
uh
environment where we have credentials
and curricula
and and and we limit the contact
between like a lateral contact amongst
learners teachers are very resentful i
can tell from my own experience with
link very resentful of any
outsider trying to get involved in
education with new ideas so they're very
much like these isolated
uh
communities like tasmania where skills
decline
to my mind the ipad represents a new
paradigm if the school system is like a
traffic light stop go red light green
light
the ipad is like the roundabout where
people make their own decisions and
people learn for themselves in an
environment of lifelong learning they
connect with other learners they connect
with other people with whom they can
exchange
as we do at link exchange my language
for your language and not just that link
by the way at a multiplicity
of websites on the internet i mean how
can we compare the creativity of people
developing educational apps for the ipad
versus the textbooks and the
institutionalized curricula we have in
in schools with the ipad as a symbol we
now can
customize to individual needs and
requirements and the teacher's not out
of the equation because the teacher if
he gets out of the school room can
actually access far more people not just
the k to 12 but all the people who want
to learn the teacher can be a source of
motivation encouragement
uh encouraging people to get active
because what we need to measure is is
how active people are in their learning
not necessarily measure them against
some arbitrary uh some arbitrary
grammar test in the case of language
learning so in summary because i'm
running out of time here we are safer
richer healthier living longer than any
time before if things have improved so
dramatically in the last little while
why be so pessimistic about the future
we need to recognize that all the dire
predictions of running out of this that
the other have never turned out to be
true because mankind is innovative and
you can't extrapolate the past into the
future and let's take that same
creativity and exchange
and innovative attitude into education
into and in particular language
education so i'd be interested in
hearing your thoughts on
ramble you just heard